ok ça lui brut allait passer une journée
avec moi voudrait slip
je vous attendrai pas si jamais vous
êtes larqué commence par le premier lieu
un endroit où je suis venu très très
très très vite vous allez comprendre
pourquoi
c'est palais de la culture
j'aime bien ça tournoi parce que c'est
une histoire de l'évolution de ma
carrière
premier concert que je dois faire en
côte d'ivoire c'était en 2008 ou 9
concert est annulé faute de billets
vendus donc c'est énormément de
frustration après du promoteur de
l'époque pour moi parce que je me disais
roi où je savais chanter des fois un peu
avant au gabon est bien passé voilà
c'est ma première en près de 10 voire et
ça commence comme ça donc j'étais un peu
frustré quand même il compte y arriver
là la première fois il faut que tu te
doutes est allé vivre ici non non par
contre si on affame le savez c'est
bizarre parce que oui j'aurais dû
détecter le pays vu que première fois
que j'ai mon concert il n'a pas lieu
parce que les gens ils seront foot et
que ça n'avait pas soulevé les foules
mais c'est quand même une ironie du sort
incroyable et
mais c'est le couac téléphoner 225 jeté
mon épouse allaient santé qu'on allait
peut-être venir ici quand j'ai rencontré
j'étais dans une chambre ont partagé une
chambre étudiante minuscule elle et moi
c'était notre première endroit dans
lequel on avait cru et c'est la chambre
des 125 f et les petits signes du destin
de loin du sol et l'équipe va continuer
par trois on va dans un endroit un peu
spécial pour moi c'est un geste est un
endroit qui représente plein de choses
mais pour moi c'est en deux temps
bizarre a commenté la honte
bushman café et c'est un stade eu
tellement multi multi tâche d'être un
hôtel un restaurant
moi je considère ce aussi un musée c'est
bien une ou deux fois j'ai pris des
photos pendant mon instagram et après je
me suis fait plus qu'un pack ventes saas
est face à un clip
d'être trop alléluia pas doré hall mais
couronne sans ma tête je m'en suis sorti
parce que jeune débrouillard
je crois en dieu et je crois en moi même
je voulais un côté harry royal qui
pensent un peu un prince à new york et
caetera et tout est mêlé prestige
prestige black excellence souvent ils
exigeaient de la formule siens qu'est ce
que tu en penses
barile les étiquettes necas comme ça
c'est moi j'ai toujours rigoler sur 10
ans s'est fait surtout pour faire des
rayons à la fnac pour savoir qui qu'est
ce que tu cherches comme disque était
bien nous ça me dérange pas les rappeurs
tension ne soyez pas déçus quand vous
allez voir une autre posture serait déjà
vers les caves
si ça n'engage que vous c'est pas un
problème si c'est en plus c'est sûr
c'est qu'on garde la junte
on demande un 10 cause un système et
peut pas dire
mais on n'est pas élu de l'arrêté qui
peut se tromper
il faut se contredire et pour moi je
vais des choses à moi des fois la vie
que j'ai mis avec le temps changent pas
d'accord avec ce que je disais ces deux
mais je sais pas des morceaux que je
voyais pour autant jeu ça me ressemble
quand même c'était moi cet état là et
c'est parce que je suis passé par cette
émotion bas qu'aujourd'hui j'ai ménagé a
fait rouler
et pascal madore qu'elle me guette calme
et emma chevaliers d'or mais reporté et
safina millions d'euros en liquide sous
le matelas
je préfère winnie à nelson mandela
violents comme un couplet de médine le
rap de bihac je viens je remédie en
galère du concert chf et à la capella
ont vite sa mère mon salon c'est
coachella je suis rockeur comme dis qui
je change pas la vie qui s'y trouvaient
pour devenir not do you speak
j'ai eu la chance d'être
le plan dur
en fait sur trois décennies
gérard y avoir
gravel jambes
faut prendre du plaisir vite faut
s'habituer à prendre du plaisir parce
qu'après
y'a plus d'horaires
concert demande beaucoup de sacrifices
donc si ça fait pas plaisir la musique
en six ans le ballon basculer pour
manger j'ai accepté deux
adios nous et après et après
on s'en sort pas du rheu